we're told to solve for y and we have
this inequality that says that the
absolute value of y plus 22 is less than
or equal to 13 and a half or 13.5 so a
good place to start is maybe to just
isolate the absolute value of y on the
left hand side of this inequality and
the best way to do that we can subtract
22 from both sides so let's subtract 22
from both sides the left-hand side these
guys cancel out that was the whole point
so you're just left with the absolute
value of y
is being less than or equal to and then
13.5 minus 22. let me do it over here
13.5
minus 22. i my brain imagines or the way
i process it i say well that's i always
like to put the pot the larger number
first so i say that's the negative of 22
minus 13.5
and 22 minus 14
is 8 so or the difference between 22 and
14 is 8 so the difference between 22 and
13 half is going to be half more than
that so this is going to be this right
here is 8.5 so it's going to be negative
8.5
negative 8.5 so we get the absolute
value of y is less than or equal to
negative 8.5
now this should cause you
some pause because when you take the
absolute value of anything what do you
know you're going to get if i tell you
if i tell you that the absolute value of
i don't know any number well we'll just
say the absolute value of a
is equal to x what do you know about x
you know that x is non-negative
x
non-negative
it's either a positive number or zero
here we're saying that y is let the
absolute value when we take the absolute
value has to be less than or equal to a
negative number it's saying that it has
to be a negative number this is saying
this is implicitly saying that y
that the absolute value of y the
absolute value of y has to be
negative
it not only has to be negative it has to
be less than or equal to negative 8.5
we know that you take the absolute value
of anything you're going to get 0 or
positive number you're going to get a
non-negative number there's no number
you can put here whose absolute value is
going to give you a negative number
especially 1 less than negative 8.5
so there is no solution to this problem
you cannot find a y that will satisfy
this
so there is no
solution
no solution